bomb loose on the floor nico through the
smoke and a big find oh and he's handing
out more than that a quick click from
simple and they're multi-beacon
that's what g2 needed
and he's looking flustered oh no such at
least a
implication that he knows where he is
and hunter parked this up nicely that is
ten folks
hunter has to come up clutch when one
kovach fails
the other
fills the void that's magnificent from
hunter
oh quick snap out of that ak-47 simple
steagle starting to warm up but only for
a moment
until there was 16 on on the board i was
not gonna believe it like i just wasn't
hunter and nico how poetic
and it's simple and bit
times it to perfection
and it's impossible
[Applause]
before we get into the video i just want
to remind you all that every second
counts is brought to you by cisco
powering the future of esports now the
stockholm major final was a clash of the
titans simple versus nico navi destroyed
every team on their way to the grand
finals without dropping a single map
simple led the charge the greatest cs go
player of all time knew that this was
his major to win and he looked
unstoppable
this has to be navis masuta surely got
nothing left planned for him not anymore
and another one from simple strings
together the double zygote is deleted
yep it's now got the angle exiles never
going to expect this bit with the second
shot connects and simple in the meantime
finds another headshot
oh and then another one
where does this guy do it shiro now the
last one alive here for gambit hoping to
be the hero oh my god that is disgusting
but on the other side of the bracket g2
were terrorizing teams well nico was
terrorizing teams going into the grand
finals nico had a higher adr and
headshot percentage than simple he was
basically smurfing the major
single-handedly carrying his team 50
seconds that's a good molotov to force
him a little bit further back there's
one of them for the follow-up as well
he's looking for the triple 45 seconds
they're all over him grenades left and
right but he lands a third and just
make it a quad going for the ace gets
shut down but despite nico's mvp level
performance nobody really thought that
g2 had much of a chance against navi i
did not believe in g2 even them coming
into playoffs uh i didn't have them
making it through into playoffs and once
they got there i was still not sold but
nico was just insane major the dude was
an at like he willed his team into the
finals i mean there were other there
were other players at different moments
and they all kind of had their different
moments at times but the one steady
factor for g2 that whole way was just
nico
and that's who i quite frankly
underestimated navi's undefeated run had
pretty much everyone predicting a swift
2-0 in their favor and once the series
got underway it was pretty clear that g2
were outclassed g2 cannot lose this
round and simple titan banger
two on two
bit and simple he has been brought low
smokes are faded he's got the angle here
simple 18 seconds and he does connect
oh maybe it's denied and bit
holds his nerve with a pistol that is
magnificent only one kit keep your eyes
on perfecto and simple
plucks
the dream if they had a smoke and they
do
jax surely can drop it oh but he's been
fumbling with his knees and they both
line up for him two more headshots for
the tally although the map seemed close
at times navi closed out ancient 16 to
11. they were one map away from victory
from simple's first ever major win but
nico wasn't done yet
if g2 could survive nuke if they could
hand navi their first defeat of the
entire tournament there was a chance for
an upset unfortunately for them navi
were on an insane win streak on nuke
well what's up next nuke rb 17 in a row
the last time they lost this map was in
may very few believed that g2 could even
compete with navi on nuke and it didn't
help that g2's track record in grand
finals over the past couple years
wasn't great hope dies last i think alex
so for g2 right we've spoken about this
three grand finals over the last two
years they've been in the grand final
time and time again but they've just
been swatted away time and time again a
map is all we're asking for here it's
going to make the series extremely
exciting going into the third if they
can put up some resistance if they can
try and replicate something that
vitality did just the other day against
rb it'll be exciting at least but g2
didn't let the doubters get to them they
wanted to fight until the very end
an amine will be tested falls off after
the first he can call himself down
simple
to turn it around
ready for it
and that's the end of that handled g2
taking care of business and look at
exactly what they're doing they're
taking the fight descent is on its way
in three versus three a powerful angle
nico needs a fresh mag even trades as he
brings the fight to them oh and he's not
found it hunter has to come up clutch
when one kovac fails
the other
fills the void that's magnificent from
hunter
can they find him can they get this kill
too amanek he's looking the right way
but boomitch he course corrects with the
spray damage if he can is best but this
is still 15 this is still 15 now for g2
wow
in round 28 up 15 to 12 it looked like
g2 had it in the back they were one
round away from a map three and nico was
poised to take the game but then
the unthinkable happened hunter and nico
how poetic
and it's simple and bit
[Music]
times it to perfection
and simple sitting no no
dismiss the shot an absolute disaster
like all of esports's most iconic plays
this major ending moment was more than
just a single whiff let's break it down
second by second if you asked most
people in the arena g2 had already
started to bottle it they'd lost four
out of the last five rounds going into
the pivotal round 28 and their economy
was in the dumps
until there was 16 on on the board i was
not going to believe it until it
happened i just know how that stuff goes
man i've watched a lot of counter-strike
not even just like the g2 memes but it's
the best team in the world you have
simple there and he's on ct side duke
like i cannot express how much
impact and how good that man is on ct
side nuke where i would ever count them
out like i just wouldn't but despite
their lack of weaponry hunter and nexa
pulled off some heroics to put g2 in a
3v2 situation he kicks open the sight
spot simple toes and oh my god
electronic call simple baits it
hunter got the bomb down but then simple
showed up to make it a 2v2 it was the
two kovach cousins against simple and
bit with the entire tournament on the
line as simple made his way further onto
the site hunter patrolled hutt
g2 didn't exactly know where bit was so
nico wrapped around the map through ramp
before entering heaven but bit was
already in heaven while simple stood on
top of hut waiting for a member of g2 to
get impatient just as nico approached
the latter into heaven [ __ ] decided to
hop down onto sight likely hoping to tap
the bomb and bait g2 out of hiding nico
caught the perfect timing navi assumed
that heaven was clear because bit was
just up there and while bit slowly crept
towards the bomb simple was watching
minnie completely unaware that nico had
him in his sights simple was dead in the
water all nico had to do was click on
his head to send the series to a third
map luckily for g2
nico happens to be an absolute god with
the deagle it's known as an unwieldy
weapon
but he's probably the best deagler in
the world the deagle is a high risk high
reward weapon it's a one-shot kill to
the head through armor from virtually
anywhere on the map but the accuracy
range is only 24.6 meters that means
that even when it looks like your
crosshair is right on someone's head the
shot can still miss and with a long
reset time between shots
you need to make that first one count
or else
but that's exactly why nico opted to
take the deagle into this eco round his
skills mean he rarely misses his shots
so the risk was low and the reward could
be huge
this was nico's moment the master of the
deagle with the best player in the world
in his crosshairs one bullet would make
simple
and navi look mortal
but that's not exactly how things played
out hunter and nico how poetic
and it's simple and bit
times it to perfection
and simple sitting no no
an absolute disaster
that was it that was again that was it
mirage was one click away
oh my
now nico has hit this shot a million
times hell he probably hits this shot in
his sleep
but in this high pressure situation with
the series in his hands he whiffed but
how did he miss this shot it looks like
his crosshairs were right on simple's
head and they were briefly here's three
clicks philip explaining exactly what
happened while ignoring the deagle's
inaccuracy for a second it looks like
the first shot was a miss a last second
adjustment from nico overshot the target
meaning he did miss ever so slightly
the second shot looked like a hit then
the third looked like it missed again
because of the last minute crouch by
simple
but three clicks goes on to say that
despite the deagle's first shot in
accuracy nico could have guaranteed the
kill on simple had he shot 1 20th of a
second sooner if anything nico was
robbed on the second shot he managed to
correct his aim and it looks like it
should have hit
but it didn't it's safe to say that if
nico had hit that shot
we would have gotten a third map and
navi's momentum would almost certainly
have been shut down bit wasn't in a
position to trade at least not easily so
if nico actually killed simple he and
hunter would have been able to play for
time and win the round 1v2 niko was
literally milliseconds away from glory
but as any cs fan knows sometimes the
shots that look easy
are actually the hardest to hit plus
nico is absolutely cursed when it comes
to winning majors when there's a 15-11
score line with him in the lead
somehow it's happened to him twice at
this point
nico's missed deagle shot marked the end
of g2's run at the major they lost the
next four rounds and the match went to
overtime he's turned it and he's got all
the time in the world for this spray
one frag away from navi returning the
favor and that will do nicely
time's a problem now gtu need to make a
decision they have to take a fight he's
so lucky he's trying to plan
but the mob didn't go down and now v
will take a 2-1 defensive half nico has
already found a frag on this low hp he'd
need another though bit ten seconds by
the plan oh no that's falling apart
that's gonna be nico there's no time he
just has to watch that clock tick down
this is it
zombie
i'm taking the major
nico hit so many incredible shots and
destroyed just about everyone all
tournament long and although it is
unlucky that he missed one crucial shot
this was always going to be simple's
major navi were the odds-on favorites to
take the trophy home nico almost flipped
the script he almost took us to a third
and final map and who knows maybe g2
would have taken that one too we've seen
crazier upsets in major grand finals
before you know i always just feel the
need to defend nikko is yes he did miss
his his one shot that we never thought
he would miss but with how much impact
how much opening kills that man got it's
not his fault they could have done
anything for those two rounds man there
were so many opportunities that one is
just gonna go down unfortunately for him
as uh
the moment you know it's unavoidable at
the end of the day though all cs fans
want are great games and g2 gave us an
incredible final map sure they didn't
get to spoil the party and ruin navi's
undefeated run
but they sure as hell made things
interesting people make mistakes it
happens but you better believe that next
time nico won't miss his chance
next time when it comes down to split
second decision making he'll pull the
trigger exactly when he needs to because
when it comes to winning silverware
every second counts
hey everyone thank you so much for
tuning in to every second counts this is
the end of our season and i just wanted
to remind you that these six episodes
were all brought to you by cisco in case
you don't know how cisco powers the
future of esports they've created the
realm a custom server that fits into a
bunch of briefcases basically and gives
league of legends and valorance
international land tournaments lagless
zero ping environments for high level
play if you want to find out more we did
a whole video about the round which you
can watch by clicking on this card right
here or by checking out the links in the
description below
thanks again for watching this season of
every second counts
[Music]
you